Squeezie:-Théo Bernard ?
Théo:-Présent !
Squeezie:-Laurène ?
Luciole:-Présente ! C'est Luciole par contre !
Squeezie:-Ta mère ! Seb ?
Seb:-Présent !
Squeezie:-Nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une fausse salle de classe.
Squeezie:-Vous l'aurez remarqué, on est dans le studio de Bigorneaux & Coquillages,
et on va aujourd'hui faire le premier opus de l'académie des cancres !
*JINGLE*
Squeezie:-Nous sommes ici, réunis, entre cancres, pour repasser quelques épreuves
*Rires* T'es infernale !
Squeezie:-Pour repasser quelques épreuves qu'on a définies,
alors, on a des épreuves qu'on peut retrouver vraiment en cours,
aujourd'hui, il y a des épreuves qui sont nawak et que y a pas du tout en cours.
Squeezie:-Il y aura 4 épreuves, le but bien évidemment c'est d'avoir les meilleures notes à la fin de chaque épreuve,
pour, à la fin de la vidéo, avoir la meilleure moyenne générale et gagner !
*Bim*
Squeezie:-Ton carnet ! Ouvrez la bouche.
Squeezie:-Alors, bien é _Oh non ! Non mais s'il vous plaît, quoi ! Vous êtes  infernaux !
Squeezie:-A chaque manche, on a le droit de tricher pour avoir la meilleure note possible,
exemple, je peux copier sur mon voisin, je peux lui demander des petites astuces, je peux etc.
Squeezie:-Mais attention ! Dans toutes les manches, même si l'épreuve est différente,
ce sera toujours sous le regard aiguisé d'un professeur certifié de l'académie de Versailles !
Squeezie:-C'est faux, c'est entièrement faux, c'est quelqu'un de la prod, c'est totalement faux !
Squeezie:-Ce professeur aura le droit de nous retirer des points s'il nous prend la main dans le sac.
Squeezie:-Il a aussi le droit de nous mettre des blâmes et une fois qu'on arrive à 3 blâmes,
on est puni au coin pendant une minute, donc ça pénalise notre équipe pendant la manche en cours.
Squeezie:-Les équipes, vous l'aurez compris, sont Seb & et Laurène contre Théo & Lucas !
Squeezie:-On commence tout de suite avec la première épreuve, la dictée !
Prof:-Bonjour à tous ! Je suis le professeur Winston, et je serai votre professeur aujourd'hui.
Prof:-Bienvenue à tous dans ma classe.
Prof:-Je veux bien que vous fassiez des petits chevalets avec vos noms de famille
vu comment vous êtes nombreux, comme ça  je vais comprendre plus facilement qui vous êtes.
Prof:-Merci beaucoup ! Alors mademoiselle, je vois pas, si vous pouviez le décaler un peu...
Prof:-Ok, Luciole.A côté de vous, il y a monsieur Poubelle, c'est ça ? *Rires* Monsieur Poubelle, enchanté.
Prof:-Monsieur Couillasse. *Rires* Ah Merde.
Prof:-Et Théo Le Rigolo.
Théo:-Oui. *Rires*
Prof:-Chut ! Chers élèves, nous allons commencer par la toute première épreuve, qui sera une dictée.
Prof:-Bien évidemment, vous ne copiez pas les uns sur les autres, je ne veux pas entendre parler qui que ce soit,
et on garde son sérieux. Et la dictée sera bien évidemment notée.
Luciole:-Sur combien, monsieur  ? Prof:-20. Luciole:-Ce sera compté dans la moyenne ? Prof:-Oui.
Prof:-Donc on commence. Première ligne : "Alors que..." Luciole:-ça s'écrit comment "Alors" ? Prof:-Chut.
Théo:-On n'a pas le droit de parler ! Prof:-"Alors que le crépuscule pointait le bout..."
Luciole:-Vous allez trop vite !
Prof:-"Alors que le crépuscule pointait le bout de son nez"
Squeezie:-On saute des lignes ? Prof:-Attendez. Oui. Enfin, Oui. *Rires*
Théo:-Attendez ! *Rires* Squeezie:-Attendez, il a dit attendez
Prof:-Vous faites comme vous voulez. "Alors que le crépuscule pointait le bout de son nez virgule
en face" *Rires* -Chut !
Attention monsieur Frit, euh monsieur Poubelle.
"le petit Enguerrand *Rires* S'égosillait face à son écran point" Monsieur Couillasse, attention !
Je vous reprends encore une fois, c'est -1. "Le … "
-Il y a une virgule, monsieur ? *Rires* -Nan, j'ai rien fait ! C'est toujours moi!
-"Après moult essais vers le St Graal" Oui, bien sûr, c'est quoi ça ?
-J'attends un coup de fil, en fait. -Vous attendez un coup de fil ? -Oui, important.
-Oui, bah écoutez, le coup de fil va attendre ici. Vous allez vous installer ici.
-Tricheur, va ! -Vous, vous êtes des putes ! Vous êtes des grosses putes !
-Monsieur vous entendez ce qu'il_ -Chut ! -Il nous a traités de putes !
moins 1 derrière, direct. -J'ai pas entendu mais ne disez plus ce terme, s'il vous plaît. -J'ai jamais  dit ce terme.
-Donc "Après moult essais vers le St Graal"_ -Vous l'avez déjà dit ! -Oui. -Pardon. *Rires*
Oui !-Pardon m'sieur -Et si vous arrêtez pas de me couper, je vais peut-être continuer.
"Le procrastineur se trouva fort chafouin lorsque l'électricité" Crrssh "Brusquement se coupa"
-Bah, mais il est sérieux ! -Monsieur Théo, vous vous croyez vraiment discret ? La prochaine fois_ -Brusquement se coupa ?
-Oui. -Je me suis trompée, j'ai mis_ -Oui, bah, oui, regardez aussi !
-Non, mais après électricité ? -"Brusquement se coupa point à la ligne"
*Rires*
-Vraiment ? Attendez, retournez votre feuille, juste pour voir, retournez là. Ok -1, en plus j'avais mis +,
vraiment, je suis nul, -2.-Il y a pas vu que c'est moi qui avait rajouté une barre !
-Vous voulez un autre moins ? -Non, non c'est bon. -Ok. "Le jeune glissa de son trône et atterrit avec fracas
sur son coccyx"
*Laurène chuchote à M.Poubelle*
-Monsieur ! C'est abusé ! - Quoi ?
Regardez on entend que eux !
-Non , non monsieur vous l'avez pas vu !
Monsieur regardez j'ai reçu une craie et le tableau est à feutres
Il vient de le faire *Rire*
Présent !